Good morning, everybody.
And welcome to the next installment of the
Big Data to Knowledge Guide to the Fundamentals
of Data Science.
This is Mark Musen from Stanford University.
And I have the pleasure of introducing today's
speaker who is a Professor Isaac Kohane from
the Harvard Medical School.
Dr. Kohane has a distinguished career.
He's currently the founding Chair of the Department
of Biomedical Informatics at Harvard and has
a long history of working in areas that range
from the molecular to the population level.
He is probably best known, most recently,
for his work as the guy who led the development
of i2b2, which is a major resource which is
now used in over 120 academic health centers
around the world as a way of managing both
clinical and molecular data.
We know that in the world of big data we talk
about volume, velocity, and variety.
And clinical data have all of that.
And it's a pleasure to introduce Zak to your
today's talk.
Thank you very much.
It's my pleasure to be here.
My name is Isaac Kohane.
I am called by most people Zak.
And I'm glad to talk to you today about considerations
of critical data for precision medicine.
Before I go further, I just want to check
with my organizers that you can see my slide--
that looks like the precision medicine slide--
and that you can hear me.
It looks good.
Good.
Thank you.
So this is a slide just to remind you of what
precision medicine was about, at least, what
we think it's about for those of us-- as I
was privileged to be-- who were members of
the National Academy of Sciences committee
that helped write the precision medicine report.
In a nutshell, we declared that we had Google
Maps MV that-- as shown on the left of the
screen-- we saw that by taking latitude and
longitude and combining it with a variety
of other data types-- namely, for example,
weather, pharmacies, traffic-- we would create
an ecosystem-- they created an ecosystem--
that now has everybody engaged in applied
geography internationally.
And we said that if we were to create a similar
information commons that was centered around
patients that gave this multiaxial view of
patients-- not only in one study at a time,
whether from, let's say, environmental exposure,
or clinical times and symptoms, or microbial
contents of your gut, but brought all together--
we would hope to create a similar productive
ecosystem by looking at each patient from
a much more well-rounded perspective rather
than the blocky kind of categorical view that
we have currently in medicine.
Some of the points I will make in my comments
today will be that most population genetics
and clinical medicine is
Some of the points I will make in my comments
today will be that most population genetics
and clinical medicine is addicted to categorical
diagnosis.
And that addiction creates some false or wrongly
taxonomized diseases and makes social and
commercial construction of disease likely--
sometimes for good, sometimes for ill.
I also want to make the point that clinical
predictive accuracy does not imply sheer physiology,
and that disease overlaps demonstrate a fundamental
problem, which precision medicine and its
approaches are trying to solve, and that clinical
data can be used to lessen the confusion.
I want to briefly show here some ROC curves
from a paper I published several years ago
about using the transcriptum of white blood
cells in patients with autism to distinguish
them from individuals who did not have autism.
And the only reason I point this out is that
these fairly good looking AUC curves-- for
a brain disease, at least, as measured by
blood transcription-- caused me to be invited
to another school in my neighborhood, the
Harvard Law School.
And when I entered that meeting, I saw an
individual who I was reminded that I thought
I had seen him on TV, on network TV, in the
past week or two.
And I couldn't figure out who it was.
I just couldn't remember.
And then it came back to me when he asked
me the following question-- why are you trying
to commit genocide on my people?
This guy is Ari Ne'eman, who has a form of
autism.
And he picks the view that a lot of these
efforts for diagnosing autism amount to trying
to filter out these individuals and eliminate
them from our population.
And therefore this constitutes a form of genocide.
And I had a lot of discussion.
But it really made me think about the diagnosis.
But I would rather-- instead of voicing my
own comments-- voice comments of a woman that
was public about these on the web.
And she said, "I think when Ari talks about
autism and I talk about autism, we're talking
about people with different clusters of autism.
I know he doesn't like that word 'cure.'
If my daughter would function the way Ari
could, I would consider her cured," said Singer.
"I have to believe my daughter doesn't want
to be spending time peeling skin off her arm."
So the point here I am making is this diagnostic
label can actually mean a lot of different
things to many different people.
And therefore, when we use them, for example,
to do a study of autism versus not autism,
the nature of that label is going to determine
how successful we are.
Just as doing a study of heart failure versus
not heart failure would be very different
if we focused it merely on heart failure due
to atherosclerosis or all the heart failures--
valvular, atherosclerotic, genetic-- sorry--
structural protein defects or infectious,
which would be lumped into what the medievalist
would call dropsy.
So in the precision medicine perspective,
I think we have to become much more careful
about how we label these things.
And perhaps less controversial but even more
vivid description of this is dwarfism, which
is often caused by
growth hormone deficiency.
And although I have a PhD in computer science,
I am trained in pediatric endocrinology.
And this is a group that endocrinologists
have long been concerned about because the
social and physical challenges of being quite
short can be considerable.
And therefore, it was a major big breakthrough
when endocrinologists discovered that they
could take the pituitaries from 60,000 cadavers
and extract from these cadavers, from these
pituitaries, the protein, growth hormone,
and then inject them into children who are
going to be much less than 5 foot tall and--
lo and behold-grew to above 5 foot tall.
The problem was that because it was extracted
from the 60,000 pituitaries, the fact that
there were a few individuals with Yacob-Creutzfeldt
diseases, slow virus, resulted in the deaths
of several children from this disease.
And you can guess how those of us-- it's actually
the previous generation before me-- felt about
having treated these kids with the best of
intent to bring them to normal height-- feeling
responsible for having caused their death
unintentionally.
And that created, first of all, a lot of happiness
when we came up with synthetic or bacterially-derived
recombinant growth hormone that worked extremely
well in making these children grow.
But because of this-- and I'll get back to
it shortly-- because of this, the place where
I learned how to practice pediatric endocrinology,
because they had the memory, personal memory
of this Yacob-Creutzfeldt episode, gave very
low doses of growth hormone because they just
felt that they needed to be conservative.
Now, in the modern genomic era, a work done
by one of my former Fellows in pediatric endocrinology
and now team colleague-- Joel Hirschhorn ran
this big study called the GIANT study.
And what he found was, in the range of normal
height, there are literally hundreds of genes,
maybe 700 genes, that are quite informative
of adult height.
But each individual gene of those hundreds
of genes bears variants that contribute only
very, very minutely to the total height.
So your overall height from perspective of
these genes is only influenced a very, very
little amount by each gene.
So this is unlike the diseases that have the
tails at the distribution of height where
extreme short stature is a cause of highly
penetrant small numbers of mutations, sometimes
a single mutation.
Which raises the question, what do you call
short stature?
What do you call that diagnosis when you have
short stature and you're not growth hormone
deficient?
What do you call it?
So it turns out-- for a variety of reasons
which I will make apparent-- we call it idiopathic
short stature.
Now, why would you want to have a diagnosis
of idiopathic short stature?
I think just to label it to be a good doctor.
But it turns out that's also useful because
it's a diagnosis that pharmaceutical companies
can use to drive the prescription of growth
hormone because it may add one or two inches
to height.
prescription of growth hormone because it
may add one or two inches to height.
And they had a very useful biomarker that's
shown here on the screen which defines height
with respect to a standard deviation score.
And that's interesting, of course, because
it means no matter how high the US population
will be, there will always be people who are
below that threshold and therefore will qualify.
Which reminds me of a story.
About 25 years ago, when I was a fellow-in-training,
I had submitted an abstract about how with
our one third of the dose of growth hormone
we were achieving high velocity in adult statures
that looked just as good as that of the general
population of those with growth hormone deficiency
who were being treated with growth hormone.
And yet we were only using a third of the
dose.
And to make a long story short, I got a threatening
phone call, as a fellow, from the chief medical
officer there essentially threatening me to
block my publications because he sat on the
editorial board of many endocrine journals.
And this was an unforgettable lesson to me
that tied to a diagnosis and tied to the biomarkers
around diagnoses are huge amounts of dollars.
And being able to assign a diagnosis is always--
not always-- is frequently going to be an
issue not just of science but of finance.
But also, I want to remind you that not only
insurers or pharmaceutical companies but even
parents are in a push around the diagnosis.
So here's a case of a father who comes in
with a 5' 6" child who's still growing.
But because he wants his son to be an athlete
and, perhaps, a basketball player, he is willing
to pay out of pocket $45,000 a year it costs
to get a growth hormone.
And this raises a bunch of questions.
A, how does this cause us to stretch our diagnostic
criteria?
And B, is the parent wrong?
Is this actually a reasonable question and
something that we will have to face a lot
in the coming years?
Next, I want to move on to-- in this context
of categorical diagnoses.
What is the interaction between clinical annotations
and genetics?
And here we're looking at interesting interaction
between genetics and a categorical assessment
of ethnicity or race and a categorical diagnosis.
And it's hypertrophic cardiomyopathy.
Hypertrophic cardiomyopathy, for those of
you who are not clinicians, is a disease that
you've actually heard of about because it
occurs, it's been reported in the newspapers
when it's famously caused, unfortunately,
athletes to die suddenly on a basketball court.
And what it is, is an inherited-well, it's
a genetic disease, sometimes inherited-- that
is also autosomal dominant-- you'll need one
copy of the gene.
And it can lead to heart failure, arrhythmias,
obstructed blood flow and sudden cardiac death.
But the important fact to recall here is,
this is 1 in 500.
And my colleague and postdoc Raj Manrai did
a study where he looked at the National Heart,
Lung, and Blood
Institute's ESP study, which used to be thought
of as big data but at 6,500 individuals, even
with exomes, is no longer considered to be
large, big data.
But if we had this disease at 1 in 500, that
would give you about that much red as you
see on that little cartoon of those individuals.
Whereas what Raj found was a lot more red
in the population, that is a lot more hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy than you'd expect for a 1 in
500 disease.
And when he then looked into what was the
ethnicity or continent of origin of those
patients, what he found was the following--
an amazing overrepresentation of those individuals
who are African American And why is that?
Well, it turns out that individuals, those
who have run the study, had in fact done what
they were supposed to do, which is have ethnically
matched case of the controls.
So that's probably the case that all the controls
were, in fact, Caucasian and I think they
sought to have Caucasian or European ancestry
cases.
But it turns out that, for example, in one
of the studies in Paris, they've included
some individuals who were from Algeria or
from Algerian descent.
And similarly in Boston-- some who had some
relatives who were not from Europe.
And what this means is that if you include
in the cases individuals who have recent lineage
to Africa, then you're going to make it such
that they're going to have a lot of alleles
that are not present in the Caucasian or European
American controls.
Because born in Africa were those few families
that thousands of years ago emigrated from
Africa to Asia and Europe, but just a few
families.
And therefore, the representation of African
genetic diversity was extremely sparse.
And therefore, when you do a case control
study and, unbeknownst to you, you have a
few individuals of African ancestry, of recent
African ancestry, in your cases, you will
have this overrepresentation of these alleles
which actually have nothing to do with hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy.
And lest you think that this is just an interesting
statistical result, shown here from one of
the leading laboratories of hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
are all those individuals who were actually
mistakenly diagnosed as a result of this kind
of mistake.
We've published this, by the way, in the New
England Journal of Medicine last summer.
And these African American individuals were
not only diagnosed and possibly treated but,
because it's autosomal dominant, family members
were also reached out too.
Because, of course, if it's autosomal dominant,
a lot family members will carry a putatively
causal variant.
And unlike this lab which went back and notified
all the families, I'm not sure-- it's hard
to know-- how many of the commercial labs
have done likewise.
But note what's happened here.
Because of imprecision of a diagnosis, asserting
that the diagnosis is a unitary thing and
also asserting that this label of ethnicity
is a unitary thing, we're making inferences
which end up to be damaging.
And it continues also with regard to the genetic
part of the reductionism.
So here we looked up in ClinicalTrials.gov
which studies are being looked at in hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy.
And
there's a trial that is open now.
And if you look here in Group 2, there is
a group that has no clinical evidence of ventricular
hypertrophy but has a mutation.
So they have a complete normal looking hearts,
and you could be as young as 10 years old.
And you'll be receiving this drug for years
as a child, and you've no clinical evidence.
And here's the kicker.
Of course, if you don't develop disease, you're
going to be considered a therapeutic success.
Where in fact, as I hope I've just suggested
to you, you may merely be a mislabel.
Now, is prediction the acid test of diagnoses?
Often in our papers we like to say, well,
if I'm able to predict this and predict it
reproducibly in multiple populations, perhaps
I'm looking at something causal and that it
relates in some fundamental way to diagnosis.
I'd like to suggest that that's probably not
the case.
Just stare at this screen for a little bit
and focus on the fact that this is a screen
that was done by Griffin Weber looking at
survival three years after test done.
This is, specifically, white blood cell count,
but Griffin has done this, as you'll see,
on hundreds of other tests.
And what it shows you is your chance of dying,
if you're like me between 50 and 59 years
old and you have a low white blood count between
12 AM and 8 AM, your chance of dying is greater
than 50% in the next three years.
Whereas if it's obtained between 8 AM and
4 PM, the chance of dying is less than 2%.
So why would that be?
No, it's not a circadian rhythm.
It's because if your blood is drawn at 3 o'clock
in the morning, it means that the doctor is
extremely worried about you.
Doctors, contrary to some opinions, are not
sadists and they will not choose to draw blood
at 3 o'clock in the morning unless they're
extremely worried about you.
So rather than treating that variance as noise,
as some data scientists will-- and this is
the part of the problem of not treating clinical
data from a knowledge-based perspective, understanding
how the data was actually obtained.
If you didn't know that, you'd treat all the
variants that you see on the screen as noise.
But in fact, it's very, very informative signal.
And it's biased.
So if you treat it as noise, you'll run aground
in some wrong conclusions.
Whereas if you understand that there's, on
the one side, patient's pathophysiology, but
also superimposed what we call health care
system dynamics, which is the behavior of
the health care system, including informed
doctors trying to do the right thing, then
only by combining these two signals will you
actually have a good understanding of how
this relates to the patient.
And in fact, if you see on this graph, on
the x-axis is the odds ratio of death, on
the y-axis is how much of the signal is related
to the lab test itself, you can see that there
are many, many lab tests where merely having
the knowing that test is obtained gives you
a prediction of higher mortality.
Of course, when you combine it-- combine the
lab value with the health system dynamics,
the fact that it was drawn at these times--
then you have a even better signal.
Next I'm going to go on to how can clinical
data be used to clarify diagnostic boundaries.
This is work done by Finale Doshi, who was
a postdoc with me and finished at MIT with
a PhD in computer science and now is at Harvard
School of Engineering and Applied sciences,
has a Assistant Professor of Computer Science.
And when I approached her about the fact that
I was actually bothered by the fact that some
pediatricians, when they were told by the
mothers that these kids with autism, their
children, the mothers would say, had these
bowel problems, and they were told by a pediatrician,
"Brain bad, tummy hurts."
And that's not my words, that's a verbatim
quote.
So what Finale did was a very nice data-driven
approach-- using the clinical data obtained
from many of chronic health records, using
the distributed query system called SHRINE
that goes over many i2b2 systems.
But I don't want to distract you with how
we got the data.
Suffice it to say, we had data on thousands
of individuals with autism.
And what Finale did is created a bit-vector
for each of these patients chunked into one
vector for each six month block, all the way
to 15 years.
And each bit in the bit-vector describes whether
that child would have one of 5,000 different
diagnoses in that six month block.
So you can think of each block as having 5,000
bits, on and on for 15 years.
And when she did that and applied an unsupervised
clustering algorithm to these patients longitudinal
data obtained from electronic health record,
what she found was quite interesting.
What she found was one group with a lot of
epilepsy-- greater than 80% of epilepsy, as
opposed to the background rate of 20% epilepsy
in general.
She found another subgroup with a lot of infections
like otitis media and sinusitis.
And-- although it's not shown here, it was
statistically significant, but not prevalent
enough to make it onto the graph-- a number
of autoimmune diseases such as inflammatory
bowel disease, Crohn's, all sorts of colitis
and type 1 diabetes.
And then there was a third subgroup with ADHD,
anxiety and-- not shown here for some of the
reasons, it was not frequent enough but it
was significant-- schizophrenia and major
depression.
So what you have here are three very distinct
biologies, three very distinct clinical courses
of three populations that if you just labeled
them as autism and did the case control with
them, you would be mixing different biologies,
as in the heart failure example I gave you
earlier on.
So that's saying that clinical data may, in
fact, help us separate these underlined diagnoses.
And note that we used an unsupervised method
to define from a datadriven perspective what
might be the distinct subgroups there.
And can we do similar things using biology
and genes?
So, for example, with Dr. Nazeen, who at a
time was a
graduate student in Bonnie Burger's group
at MIT, we did a study looking at gene expression
in one of the pathways that we had uncovered
in that earlier autism expression study that
I told you about-- namely, the innate immune
pathway.
And so we took the KEGG innate immune pathway
and we sent across a whole bunch of diseases
that are shown on the right.
We posted this in Genome Biology.
To what extent are these genes dysregulated
in these different diseases?
As you can see here, there's quite a lot of
overlap.
But a way to, perhaps, quantify it better
is to just ask, how does gene expression just
in that pathway classify all those different
diseases?
And although it's not at the level of clinical
action ability, what you do see here is that
all of those diseases can be classified, somewhat
effectively, with errors in the curve, specifically
different from random, and some of them quite
a bit so, just on base of that innate immune
pathway.
So that tells us there's a lot of biological
overlap between these different diseases.
And that's important not only for classification
but thinking about not only the mechanism
of disease but how you're going to treat it
and, perhaps, repurpose drugs that are used
to treat one disease to another disease.
And really ask the question-- for example,
in the psychiatric diseases, psychiatrists
are very fast to acknowledge that there is
a fairly significant overlap in the symptomatology
of these different diseases.
And because, as I've, I hope, convinced you,
there is a lot of financial incentives to
have different diagnoses as well as personal
incentives to have different diagnoses.
You can better appreciate how some of these
psychiatric diseases such as autism-- or neurodevelopmental
diseases such as autism-- when there was a
reclassification of autism in the DSM-5 manual,
there was an enormous furor nationwide.
And on the one hand, I want to smile because
I often tease Mark Musen about how arcane
some of his work on ontologies are.
But in this case, the ontology of the DSM-5
was making the front page of many newspapers
because it was so important how patients were
being piled into that different diagnoses.
But note that what happens when you pile individuals
into this categorical diagnosis, it causes
different financial and social effects to
be met.
And the claim that I hope I'm beginning to
bolster is that from a data-driven perspective,
we can do a far more transparent and robust
job of defining what actually constitutes
these diseases.
So as I argued just now, there's implications
for study and for treatment.
You might want to study not all autisms compared
to, let's say, neurotypical individuals but
pick a subgroup that are much more biologically
similar to one another, just as you would
for heart failure.
And if you went to a genetics-first approach,
it would not be apparent that there are these
subsets, so the scene was just not strong
enough from a genetics-first or genetics-only
approach.
And clinicians might miss it because even
if you had a huge practice of autism, you
might easily miss the fact that there was
this overlap in this patient of, let's say,
inflammatory bowel disease.
Because even if you have a lifetime practice
of 1,000 children with autism, which, by the
way, is a phenomenally large practice, you
probably wouldn't expect to have more than
10 individuals of inflammatory bowel disease.
So over a lifetime, you might just ascribe
that to random bad luck.
And then I just want to emphasize again the
unsupervised nature of the example I gave
you about clustering the electronic health
records versus the self-referential and circular
supervised labeling.
Because if we start with a definitional categorical
diagnosis, we're going to be stuck with all
the consequences of that, which, by the way--
if we use artificial intelligence techniques,
as we're beginning to do, such as deep learning
against images, but we're using as the gold
standard our categorical diagnoses-- we are
in some sense going to be limiting the efficacy
with this big data of our diagnostic support.
Because these big data algorithms will be
limited to the supposed gold standard definitions
through the supervised learning.
And so again, what I'm trying to argue for
is let's look at longitudinal large datasets
on populations to drive in a much more objective
way what constitutes our diagnoses.
And I also want to argue for a multimodal-first
exploration that is not necessarily just going
phenotype-first or genetics-first.
But as many people on this phone call have,
in fact, in their own work illustrated, going
at both-- in that case, both modalities, but
if there are more than two, in multiple modalities
at the same time-- and in our modern machine
learning frameworks there are no theoretical
reasons, at least, why we should not do that.
What about when there is no diagnosis?
How can we use clinical data and big data,
perhaps, to get there?
So this is where I'm very proud, actually,
to describe my involvement in something called
the Undiagnosed Diseases Network, which is
an offshoot from the very successful Undiagnosed
Diseases Program at the NIH, where we said--
and I'm a PI on the Coordinating Center--
where we conceived of this network as being
hub-hosted where all that data, all the genomic
data, would be stored in the cloud or all
the clinical data would be stored in a cloud.
And those of you who are involved with human
study subjects trials will recognize that
it was a major achievement for us to get,
all of a sudden, academic health centers,
including the NIH, to agree to a single protocol
that A, said that they would go with this
shared data resource, that everybody within
the network would be able to see the data.
And furthermore, a patient could be referred
into this network and then go wherever they
needed to be referred to within this network,
so going from one hospital to a completely
different hospital system-- something that
does not happen usually.
By doing this, by taking these patients who
have had already, prior to their application
to this network, a Hejira through multiple
health care systems trying to get a diagnosis,
we were able to therefore obtain genome, whole
genome sequencing or exome sequencing, phenotypic
evaluation and coding per the HPO terminology,
and referring these patients to the right
academic health centers where the right individual
can evaluate them.
I should point out in this network we also
have two sequencing centers.
We also have a biological validation because
you can appreciate that many mutations that
look like there may be loss of function often
don't create loss of function.
So Drosophila and zebrafish core we're using
CRISPR.
They knock in the human mutation equivalent
into these organisms to see if it causes a
phenotype, so we can better assess the pathogenicity
of these variants.
And the point is, based on the approach that
was pioneered at the UDP we're finding that
we're making a lot of diagnoses.
And this is now out of date.
We have received well over, I think, 1,100
applications, and over 500 or 600 are under
review, and, actually, over 500 participants
have been accepted, and, I think, on the order
of 80 new diagnoses have been made.
When there's no diagnosis, what we're doing
now is, if there's a high probability causal
variant, we're going to link- as we have for,
I think, on the order of 80 patients of this
new diagnostic label-- linking the clinical
findings in that patient to that variant.
But I think we have to be vigilant.
Because do all individuals with that variant
have disease?
I think the probands that we've identified
do have a causal link from that variant to
that disease.
But how does genetic background, with individuals'
different genetic background and different
environmental exposures, have a phenotype
that's affected by that variant?
And another way I can say it is, we know intuitively
and mathematically that the probability of
disease given the variant is not the same
thing as the probability of the variant given
the disease.
But in practice, we don't behave as if we
know this.
And for a long time, there was a number of
variants in the HFE gene which were considered
to be pathogenic for hemochromatosis.
And indeed, if you look at hereditary hemochromatosis
clinics, 80% of individuals in those clinics
will have one of a small number of variants
in each HFE mutation, in each HFE gene.
But then a study was done, an amazing study
was done at Kaiser Permanente by researchers
from Scripps where they genotyped-- I believe
it was-- over 44,000 individuals with hemochromatosis.
And they found, I think, 151 who were homozygous
for one of those mutations.
And of those 151 only one had any clinical
evidence or found a history of hemochromatosis.
So the penetrance went from 80% in the hereditary
hemochromatosis clinic to a less than 1%.
And that's because the individuals at Kaiser
had very different genetic backgrounds and
very different exposures.
And in case that doesn't convince you, some
other papers which looked at three different
mouse strains with HFE mutation-- of those
mouse strains only one of the three mouse
strains showed evidence of hemochromatosis.
So
the point is, we are making these new diagnoses
in the Undiagnosed Diseases Network, but we
have to be careful not to make the same error.
And the way to avoid making that same error
is going to be the emergence of all these
large-scale population screening-- sorry--
genomic sequencing, which will give us what
are the probabilities of those variants in
the general population so that we can have
a better sense of how they are linked to health
and disease.
In closing, I want to ask the following question.
Why is medicine so dependent on categorical
diagnoses?
Well, there was a question that was asked
in the New England Journal of Medicine 33
years ago.
They basically asked-- let me-- they literally
asked, if you have a disease that's 1 in 1,000
and you have a test that has a sensitivity
of a 100% and have a specificity of 95%--
so that's a very good looking test, 100% sensitive,
95% specific.
Very few genetic tests can even approach that
level of performance.
So with this 1 in 1,000 disease, what's the
probability of having disease if you test
positive in that test?
A bunch of Harvard doctors and students were
asked to study it 33 years ago and reported
upon it in the New England Journal.
And About half of the doctors answered, greater
than 90%.
And half of the doctors answered, around 1%
to 2%.
And just for those of you who are falling
asleep, I'll just remind you that right answer
is-- if you've 1,000 individuals, one will
be a true positive because it's 1 in 1,000
disease.
And because it's 95% specific, you'll have
50 false positives.
So you'll have 51 positives total, only one
of them are true.
So if you tested positive on that genetic
test with those remarkable characteristics,
nonetheless, your chance of having the disease
is less than 2%.
33 years later we ran the same test on heart
doctors and students, and we essentially found
exactly the same distribution.
But because we were using the same question,
we've been publishing not in the New England
Journal but in Journal of Internal Medicine.
So my point is this-- human beings are not
good probabilistic machines.
We We're not innate Bayesian machines intuitively.
And therefore, having a categorical diagnosis
is really cognitively necessary for us.
But that creates a real problem when we're
entering this age of millions of genetic tests.
How are we going to navigate the fact that
we're not natural Bayesian machines?
I will now summarize so that I can get to
any questions.
Our addiction to categorical diagnoses is
cognitively useful and will likely continue
for that reason.
But categorical diagnosis can result in spurious
biological and clinical inference.
And it's often manipulated for dollars or
for a non-pecuniary secondary agenda.
I want to point out and remind us that the
prediction of diagnostic class does not necessarily
provide evidence of biological etiology.
And I hope I've begun to convince you, at
least, that diagnoses are more robust when
they're data-driven, when you formally model
health system dynamics for clinically acquired
data, that it's statistically-informed, that
in the
spirit of the precision medicine report, when
it's multimodal, when you're looking at more
than one data type at a time, you're actually
going to do better.
And to avoid circularity of this diagnostic
categorical problem having unsupervised or
lightly supervised approach rather than a
fully supervised approach may be advisable.
And the cause, the first point-- because of
the cognitive utility of categorical diagnoses
I think we have very little choice at this
point, other than to recognize the necessity
of having computational decision support that
will, actually, substitute for our non-Bayesian
wetware with computational software and hardware
that does in fact do the appropriate probabilistic
assessment of post-test probability of various
disease combinations.
And with that, I want to thank you for your
patience and thank my collaborators for their
work.
And I'll stop here and I'll see if there are
any questions.
And I'll leave it to Mark to be master of
ceremonies.
Thank you, Zak.
That was a great talk.
I really appreciate that, as do all the people
listening on the webinar.
As you know, there is a box where you can
type in your questions.
And what I will do is try to synthesize and
restate the questions so we can have a little
bit of order as we ask Zak to expand on some
of the issues that he's raised today.
So please think about your questions, put
them into the question box.
And while you're doing that, let me ask Zak.
You've raised lots of issues about the messiness
with which we categorize disease, with the
messiness with which we record data, basically
with all the complexities of clinical information.
And I'm just wondering, what are the implications
of all that for electronic health records?
If we could start from scratch, how would
you design an EHR to accommodate all of this?
Well, first of all, I want to paint a positive
version of that.
The same argument can be made about claims
data.
Claims data are comprehensive so they don't
have esteemed bias.
But they're certainly biased for financial
gain.
And there's only more core screened than many
EHRs.
But smart and meticulous individuals have
been able to use the claims data to answer
real questions by combining in various creative
probabilistic fashion different claims codes
to identify the right patient's populations.
Similarly, I will say that you can use, perhaps,
using some of the methods I referred to but
not necessarily-- you can actually go against
the existing messy data, codified data, in
a variety of ways to obtain some probabilistic
estimates of what the underlying true patient
[INAUDIBLE] are.
But to answer your question directly, if I
were, perhaps, at Google, which I'm not, I
might argue that their ontologists will wipe
the floor with you regularly just by brute
force machine learning, statistical machine
learning, over the textual corpora.
And we actually never fully-- not until the
very end do we any labeling of ontologies,
but we actually calculate patients' similarity
across, for example, all the word vectors,
across all these patients.
So I would say that I would not redesigned
the EHRs from scratch because we've already
spent several billion
dollars.
But I would, perhaps, in addition to being
optimistic on how we can use codified data,
I think there is a much more modern statistical
framework.
If you look at the clinical nodes, that will
be quite helpful.
Ironically, actually, some of the cut-and-paste
facilities in EHRs will actually take away
from some of the signal in these clinical
nodes.
Because, of course, people like cutting and
pasting but it, of course, takes away a lot
of signal from the richness that normally
is in human text.
Thanks.
What There are two questions.
You get these requests to put up your conclusions
slide against so people can take a look at
those bullet points.
Already.
Can you just back up your side?
And question from an ontology lover.
"What is your advice to librarians working
with EMR bank, REDCap groups, et cetera, given
our tendency to categorize?
How can we help our patrons think and plan
for a new paradigm?
We work with researchers, physicians who contribute
to the classification, reclassification efforts
of diseases.
What would you tell these people?"
I'll tell them two things.
First of all, a very tactical thing to do
is to say, why don't you have your researchers
at least analyze in two ways-- the way they
originally did it, but then use a set of categorizations
that lump together similar things relatively
robustly like PheWAS codes.
PheWAS codes were developed at Vanderbilt
in order for them to be able to look at different
diseases because, of course, ICD-9 does not
do a great job of maintaining that kind of
hierarchy.
But even PheWAS itself is insufficient.
But I would say that if we use that or whatever
ontology, Mark, you would-you're far more
experienced then I am-- would point to, but
I found that PheWAS codes, by the way, are,
actually, quite useful in rolling it up.
You can see whether it's finding robust association,
robust cluster rather than just an artifact
of the ontology.
The harder way to do it-- but the one that's,
I think, much more consonant with our BD2K
spirit-- is to actually use the primary data
itself and say, first, let's classify the
data by the primary data processing, principle
component analysis, or some other dimensionality
reduction technique to see if these patients
that we've labeled in a certain way are, in
fact, clustered together.
Because that will give you a good smell test
whether the categorization that you're using
is, in fact, robust relative to the question
you're asking.
There's an interesting corollary question
that comes from Jim Semino.
What are the implications for race as a demographic?
I think that this is a very, very tough one
because I think I showed you how not doing
this in one way created a lot
of problems.
And so we're stuck with the following.
The good news used to be that self-identified
race correlates well with what the EHR thinks
your race is.
In other words, administrators are tracking
patients somewhat.
The problem is that ethical work, as well
as we've come in increasingly multiracial
society.
So I think that what we're going to have to
start doing is using different modalities
depending on what the purpose is.
So if you really want to find continent of
origin, probably looking at a few hundred
SNPs-- and that's all it takes these days.
Just a few hundred SNPs have been identified
that give fairly reliable continent of origin
and will give you the mixture of continental
origin.
Those of you who've used 23andMe can see that.
And I think that's the answer, by the way,
of how we will have to categorize patients.
So if you want to do a case control study,
as has been done in population genetics now
for a long time but not in clinical medicine,
we'll have to compare populations on those
genetic backgrounds as determined by the SNPs.
But that only satisfies a certain class of
questions.
There are other classes of questions that
are still going to be much more informed by
what your identification is.
And that's a much more complicated story.
And I'm sure we could have, and perhaps should
have, a much longer discussion about.
Another questioner wants to know what are
the implications for gender and sex, given
that we're moving into an era where gender
and sex should not be viewed as binary classifications.
Well, speaking as a pediatric endocrinologist,
I think that's a very good question.
And certainly, just having the male and female
genders on the electronic health record for
the most part is not very helpful in supporting
that diagnose.
Now, I know that the EHRs have changed recently
to support that multiplicity of gender assignments.
But it's not clear how they're being informed--
whether by a patient, by the clinician.
So if we want to use these for studies, I
think somebody's going to have to come together
and decide how we're going to represent it
in a way that reflects both, and maybe simultaneously,
biological measurements and patient identity.
Because we recognize that in this identity
there is what your sexual organs look like,
what your chromosomal arrangement looks like,
where your mutations are affecting or not
different hormones that are associated with
different traditional gender identities.
So again, I think that there's a truly biological
part of this that I think we can and should
capture in EHRs.
But then there's also the self-identification
part, which I know is complicated but, I think,
also does inform us about some aspects of
the patient that we have to also figure out
how to capture in the EHR.
And I'm not clear that we have done that yet.
I agree.
Zak, we've reached the end of the hour.
And I want to thank you for really illuminating
talk.
If you look at the questions that are still
posted, you'll see a number of listeners have
basically just posted a thank you because
this is such a stimulating conversation.
Really want to thank you for your contribution
and thank you everyone who dialed in today.
Thank you very much for your attention.